[Music]
hey party people welcome to a
hot and steamy episode of sju's honest
trailer commentaries uh
because my ac is out and i'm in the
valley now so
i'm going to slowly be turning into a
puddle as the show progresses you know
the drill though
we talk about the honest trailer we talk
about our thoughts and feelings behind
it
the deleted scenes that we cut from the
final video and
uh comments and questions from viewers
like you then we'll tell you what next
week's trailer is going to be in a super
cryptic riddle that i will come up with
on the spot um
danielle hello hi hello i'm so sorry
about your uh ac that bums me out yeah
it's fine it'll
it'll fix itself
that's how that works i got my iced
coffee i'm chilling and i'm here to talk
about uh black widow
um a film that uh
felt like um you know like like a marvel
regular
to me like i'll have the usual you know
it's like a turkey club for lunch it's
like yeah i've had that a million times
before and
it i'm not gonna ever think about it
again but it was satisfying at the time
i enjoyed it what's next yeah i like
havarti harvardian turkey is really good
like i like a good i like
you know if like this was uh i feel like
this was
unfortunately like a little too late um
this would have been better as one of
the as someone on twitter and i can't
remember who said it called it one of
the hat movies
um i feel like they said that if there's
two different kinds of of marvel movies
there's like the big
cosmic movies and then there's the hat
ones but they didn't wear the hats in
this one
you know what i know horrible characters
trying to hide they they wear the heidi
hat that
yeah he likes um because kevin feige
wears them
he just has a closet full of those hats
um
but yeah like i thought that this was
this was definitely like a fun movie
it's not my favorite marvel movie but
it's not it's it's uh i feel like i keep
saying this it's a mid
you know like it just it hits it it's
good for going out with friends but i
don't know if i would necessarily
uh call it a huge party or necessarily
do it sober
or meaning this is dad's
dad's stash it's it's a little more
mellow and it's uh yeah it's like it was
back in the 70s um
but uh yeah you said you said something
interesting about it coming too late
and i i understand the idea behind
um wanting to know more about black
widow because she has been
like an underserved character in the mcu
and has just been used as
not a foil but like uh like a mirror to
reflect the men's problems back at them
and
you know and help them overcome them but
because of that i was never looking
forward to a solo black widow movie i
was like yeah it's
it's not a very well written character
why would i care more she wound up
becoming like the mom
of the group so if anything i was
looking forward to especially with this
and like its focus on
uh family as tom toretto would say
um i was looking forward to it if only
so that there would be someone else
finally being the mom and so this one
character didn't have to like put that
on her shoulders
because like she was introduced as this
kind of like badass
you know super spy and then eventually
she became like the caretaker because
that's what movies do to women
um so i was looking forward to a
different woman being able to do this
and her just being badass the entire
time and i wish that this would have
come
after like a winter soldier or something
like that i feel like bucky should be
the new mom the new
the domestic i agree look he's been out
in wakanda
he's been raising goats like he's
definitely got some of that good
caretaker energy
yeah he should be just like you know
fussing over everyone back at the hq and
you know tending the ground maybe
he'll have goats raise goats on tony
stark's avengers cabin or something like
that
he definitely has an herb garden 100
but i i did like uh there's a lot that i
liked about this film i liked um
the i liked every new character they
introduced sons
the the villains which is par for the
course with marvel um
taskmaster and and and drankoff was it
uh not
not the best that uh not gonna top
anyone's list although
sadly it probably falls in the middle um
but i thought that the family dynamic
stuff was really good maybe just because
i missed the americans but
that's cool i like i like fake russian
families uh
in hiding in cold war america that was a
great cold open
and uh that cold open was like one of
the best
like that the cold open and then the
actual credit sequence
i literally i'm gonna be really honest i
cried during that credit sequence and i
know
like part of it is maybe yeah like i
didn't know seattle and you're hearing
sad nirvana cover i was just about to
say i think part of it is that i'm a
little homesick i haven't been home in a
couple of years
um but it was definitely like that
credit sequence is one of the best in
the mcu and i kind of wish it had that
like weird oliver stoney
vibe during the whole movie yeah that'd
be great um
and i thought it was a weird choice of
song um but then in retrospect
smells like teen spirit is a subtle
allusion to the fact that the bad guy's
power is he smells so bad you can't hurt
him
[Laughter]
i think it actually works on so many
levels open your third eyes benny
uh i'm sure we have a lot more to say
and we'll say it as we watch the odds
trailer
four black widow roll it
[Music]
she helped tony get his mojo
talk to him there but now
natasha finally gets to tell her own
story about the time she helped her own
replacement join the mcu
still got nothing on aaron um william
are you meal
black widow you've been waiting there's
possibilities
mcu's first female superhero hold pause
and we'll just talk more
big thoughts little thoughts thoughts
about black widow
um i i gotta tell you uh if this was
supposed to
build excitement for uh elena taking on
the mantle
i'm all in if this was supposed to build
excitement for hawkeye
i'm still out well i will look i will
if if we get a guarantee because there's
that post-credits scene and of course
i'm assuming that if you've seen the
trailer then you've watched the movie
um but if you can see that that
you know post-credits scene elena being
in hawkeye
is the only thing so far that's made me
super excited for hawkeye
yeah i think that um elena period is uh
you know we were gonna wait until we got
into it but we'll just say it now like
she steals this movie i mean she's she
puts it
she puts the movie on her vest and she
and she runs with
it i think that uh the mcu is so
so lucky to have uh uh florence
and i mean my god they just keep they
keep plucking people from
uh having like promising long-running
indie movie careers
and saying like nope nope you do marvel
now and they're so lucky to have her
yeah no that's one of my favorite things
that they do is uh
and then you get to do the thing the big
movie in the little movie so hopefully
um she'll continue to be able to do
little movies in 10 years
and she can do some really good things
something good on stars that we'll all
watch or something on whatever streaming
service that we like
well yeah i mean she had like in in the
olden days she'd have like
a string of more she'd be a chloe 7y
she'd do like 12 824 movies in a row but
um
but now she gets to do one on one off
with marvel and yeah i mean
look this isn't to uh denigrate black
widow and scarlett johansson who are
a fantastic character overall in the
comics and fantastic actress but
i like already like elena a lot more and
i'm more interested to see what happens
to her um
it's funny how how far a little
personality and a little character
development will take yeah
yeah um oh we're good all right
well let's uh let's let's dive back in
maybe we can
been waiting to see the mcu's first
female superhero
in her own movie and waiting and
waiting and waiting but natasha romanov
is finally getting the mid-tier solo
marvel movie
she deserves because the ultimate sign
of respect in pop culture
is getting your chance to keep important
object x out of the hands of military
leader y
by taking down massive airship z i know
marvel's taking some risks here and
there but this one definitely sticks to
the old plan
so this was the big plan huh i like your
plan
except it sucks so let me do the plan we
need a plan of attack
i have a plan attack first of all you're
copying me from when i said i had a plan
what about our plan
american bachelors in europe that's your
plan that's a solo plan come on this is
my plan
my plan was to drive us away it's the
plan
i mean that's just that's not even
there's no reason to put that in the
honest trailer except it just grinds my
gears
i'm just thinking that every marvel
movie seems to have
the same beat where they're like your
plan sucks my plan's good why don't you
do your plan my plan like
it just gets a little samey after a
while and
uh i don't know pet peeve do you does
that uh annoy you danielle d
does anyone else even notice this um no
i did not notice it until we started
doing the thing and now it's going to be
one of those things that i could never
unhear
um because i do think that the best beat
of that that they did was the one with
uh the one in infinity war infinity
whatever it's been there's a million
marvel movies
um but i think that that was the best
one that they've done this one i only
liked because i like the dynamic between
like that big sister little sister one
and for the rest of them it's just like
two egos butting heads
and with this one it's definitely like
at least you know they've got that kind
of
it makes sense it's like an adversarial
relationship true true true
yeah and there's more like there's some
in ant-man and stuff like that it's
always just like
your plan is stupid and it's just so
i don't know it's just so samey like
find a new find a new beat
at least find a new word say strategy or
something
oh god if we brought in i'm sure there's
uh also scenes where it's like your
strategy is terrible my strategy is
superior
actually that's d that's dc dc
uh your tactics are inferior to mine all
right uh keep going
real natasha romanov a woman struggling
to overcome the trauma
of being a child actor i remember this
day
we shot christmas thanksgiving easter
and summer vacation all on monday
she's got nothing but her wits and flips
to protect her in a dangerous world of
super spies
although at some point she entered the
cheat code that turns off environmental
damage
really good at falling yeah
that one though i mean that made me
pause
that that moment made me laugh out loud
whereas like i was like oh my god
they killed black widow she just got
picked back up i assume it's the body
armor or it's just like
on her head to shift like a plate in her
skull
she's got a super wig and that wig
protects her dome
yeah for one thing like the watching
that i was like
is this to prepare us for the fact that
she falls in the end game we just showed
that she's really good at falling and
has no fear of
it oh good point because she can totally
now like get back up after end game and
we'll believe it
she falls down and then she gets up
again you're never gonna get black widow
down
uh i mean it look it didn't break the
immersion for me because it's just like
okay like it's a comic book movie but at
the same time
i don't know it it it helps it just
helps plot wise when like oh
she took a little nip of super soldier
serum like she just took a little sip
or something i assume what is it the
lobotomy that helps it so it's just like
hashtag oh because she doesn't have
a
uterus she's able to absorb you have a
uterus and they cut into her brain and
i'm like
all right okay yeah yeah there you go
yeah it's her
it's her training that's what it was oh
yeah she was trained to be able to fall
down multiple stories worth of things
all right it's falling day everybody
everybody practices
and then if you die you die you know
rocky 4 style
oh man all right keep going what
and for one scene she turns into mega
man but they never mention it again
what journey to russia where everyone
speaks with their best
uh let's call it sakovian accent or just
doesn't even try
i was the family reunion unless you're
actually from eastern europe in which
case
you are mute and me the surrogate family
who raised black widow back in her 90s
ghost world phase
there's red guardian david harper's
latest attempt to hide in a siberian
prison until everyone forgets about the
hellboy remake
melina the hellboy roommate
bad but entertaining bad i mean just so
ridiculous
that uh it's hard to hate for me but
uh we'll we'll probably talk about that
later at some point
did you ever did you give the hellboy
remake 90 minutes of your time
i did not give the hell boy remake 90
minutes of my time i certainly didn't
uh but i'll put it on the list
especially if we're going to talk about
that at another time
yeah i think it could be in our futures
all right anyways keep going molina
a monster war criminal elena tortures
pigs
and played a willing active role in
kidnapping little girls and brainwashing
them into femme bods
but she regrets it so no harm no foul
mama take care of yourself
okay don't worry i got this
so she only she only cares about two
little girls though she doesn't care
about the whole army of the rest of the
that was wild she's like a a a stone
cold psychopath and i i missed
the moment where um
she's redeemed i guess uh yeah it's
basically like
they they make it look like she's evil
and then all of a sudden
there's the we're all wearing headsets
except for
david scene and like that's yeah
everyone but red guardian has a headset
and that's what's like oh i guess she's
good now
and so we really miss the part where she
actually turns good
because yeah like one of the first
things we see
aside from the period where they're in
the americans
um she is literally just like oh i'll
eventually let this pig breathe
and we're supposed to believe that she
cares about these pigs but it's like
she doesn't um she doesn't but you know
pigs aside she's
mind controlling little girls to be
murdered and kidnapped little girls to
be murderers
and like in a very willing and
clear-eyed way like okay drake off like
he's evil he's got a plan to take over
the world and
red guardian like he's kind of a dummy
who like
he's kind of an ideologue like kind of
easily brainwashed soldier guy like
she's smart
she knows exactly what she's doing and
she's like yeah good plan i'm in
we established that like only one in 20
girls makes it like in the beginning it
smells like teen spirit they're
literally
putting a thing over uh one of the girls
by the grateful yeah
yeah the only natural resource we have
too much of girls
also i don't just all the widows of
color die
very early oh well that's yeah that's a
deleted scene but yes they uh
uh yeah he he doesn't see color when it
comes to killing um
the blackest of widows die first yes
they do they do
uh all right keep going and elena the
mischievous little braided hair sister
from little women
who's now the mischievous little braided
hair sister who's murdered untold
hundreds of people
i'm not the killer that little girls
call their hero i don't know elena say
three cute things about your vest and
i'll take a whole russian prison's worth
of dead bodies off your ledger it has a
lot of pockets
but i use them all the time and i made
some of my own modifications i know how
much you like it
does have a lot of pockets very handy
pockets yeah it's so cool right
it's great yes and you can put so much
stuff in there
you wouldn't even know oh she likes the
best so cute
awesome women love pockets
i can't i can't stress enough how much a
lady loves a pocket
i don't know what life would be like
without pockets i mean have you ever
seen a woman find a dress with pockets
in it we will talk about it for
literal days and it's got a pocket yeah
yeah it's got pockets if you've ever
listened to my favorite murder they
literally oh buy dresses with pockets
and they're always like it's got pockets
and then they talk about
uh horrific serial killers
yeah the two best things in life um yeah
i i think that
um you you mentioned danielle in your
notes that like i don't think the
mcu is ready for the roblox 90s pockets
everywhere phase but
here we are here we go we found that
would be funny as if every character
then becomes like just full of
little pouches and pockets look when
they introduce the x-men if they don't
have
full-on bomber jackets and those like
belts that for some reason go here and
then
also go around like those seat belt
looking belts with a bunch of pockets i
don't want it
well like it's not necessarily for ammo
it's just pouch pouch pouch just pouch
after pouch after pouch
i assume that's where they keep their
gum yeah
definitely all right uh keep going i
want i want that best i think we all
want a best this would be a cool way to
die
and we don't care how many people died
again because man pause
another thing look there's a shot
there's a granted there's a shot of
people going
back inside the prison okay they're
still buried under an avalanche
like yeah everybody's going to go save
them for a long time
yeah they're still under what like tons
of snowpack
which gets really hard and then maybe
turns into black eyes they're still
super dupes dead all of them to like get
one guy
out and also they're all what like
political prisoners like we don't know
what's going on in that prison yeah i
mean i don't know if it's like
uh uh you know well i guess it's the
real world you know that's that's that's
putin's russia right there because the
bill clinton's in this movie too like
and it's a
a bunch of political prisoners in russia
all buried under the ice because
uh uh that she needed to talk to her
fake dad could have been an email
just like one guy and she even told him
like keep it quiet
and yeah uh whatever side of the
spectrum you're on
guards they're they're all dead too all
the prisoners all the guards everybody's
just buried under the ice
and elena's like this is a cool way to
die she didn't ask any of the
other like 400 people in that prison if
they agreed
that might be the biggest like marvel
body count right there
yeah it's a pretty big body count for
sure yeah
anyways keep playing but a story that
dares to ask
what if the most powerful force on earth
girl power
fell into the wrong hands as the evil
mastermind harvey weinstein i mean drake
off
builds a floating fortress that evades
detection because
it's cloudy and uses the power of his
colossal stank to keep him safe
prevents you from committing violence
against you
nope nope nope because fairmont when i
think pheromones i think sex and sexy
because that's the way that it's usually
now you'll think a stinky ray winston
and you'll be powerless look which can
still be sexy i guess under the right
circumstances
the problem with this is um and look and
i
i not to be too like the pick apart the
logic of
a superhero film but um guns
you know guns you can shoot someone from
outside smelling distance
unless he's so powerfully stinky that
like
even you know a sniper on a roof like
two buildings over it could be like
never mind i can't i just can't he's got
like that pepe the pew tank going on
yeah like the oh it should have come out
of his body and then turned into a
little finger and then done the little
thing under the nose
yeah like a pie cooling on a windowsill
in a mini tune
um that's what marvel needs more of
stink lines uh all right keep going he's
infiltrated the halls of power with a
sister soldier hood of mind controlled
assassins
and doing his evil bidding is the
taskmaster a martial artist with the
ability to mimic any hero's moves
but none of their personality or
charisma
because now that marvel has themselves a
deadpool someone had to become the
deadpool from wolverine origins
so if you're looking for a lethal nikita
but a lot
or what if charlie's angels but evil or
what if propaganda was used to twist
trafficked young girls towards the
nefarious purposes of the rich and
powerful
including bill clinton and condoleezza
rice but like
could also be a ride at disneyland then
strap in for a movie that's good at
being pretty much everything
except a black widow solo film
yeah story i mean i guess that's the
the one line review is i liked
everything about it except i don't feel
like i
really know more or like black widow
more than when i came in which i guess
means it failed even though i was
entertained
yeah like it's supposed to be about to
me this feels more like a
elena introduction film than a black
widow movie
yeah it's like here's a here's a new
super team of spies that she also
supported
back yeah yeah also kind of help but
yeah that's the problem is like when the
uh when the character is like
stoic sullen badass trained mind
controlled operative
from day one like not day one like when
she was like nine years old like
there's not much to discover except like
just the practicalities of how that
happened like there's not much character
growth if she's just been a killer
until like the avengers movies right
it's like it's like in the jason bourne
movies when you found out like
oh he was actually like fud
fudman fudd gump like somebody had some
dumb name
and it's like okay he's like he was like
a soldier who signed up to do this
he's like great great i'm glad glad we
had that revelation yeah like we and in
this it's like
it's not even the whole thing with her
family is like they were only a family
for three years
and they treat it like it's like
obviously the most important part of her
life
but she didn't know them for very long
um so
any revelations we would have gotten
again that's why i wish that they would
have focused more on like the training
thing although i know we don't want to
see another
a bunch of girls doing ballet or
whatever and i definitely don't need to
see an on-camera hysterectomy
which that joke was really funny i want
to at least oh they did a great job of
like
taking a a really dumb whedon line and
a plot point really and turning it into
like that was great that was that was
fantastic yeah they did a really good
job of that
uh i have no i have no uterus and her is
museum squirrel voice
um i thought that they did really good
with that but yeah no like you don't
really it's just a
it feels like a side quest like it's a
side adventure yeah
i feel like they could have and they had
that movie in there of like her on the
run from
thunderbolt ross and from shield and
like it could have been
present day with some flashbacks or or
yeah just she's on the run from her
government her own government so she has
to hide out with this surrogate family
that she used to have i don't know just
seemed
cleaner than like there's a new super
villain and he's got a
he's got a floating castle and he stinks
and his daughter is supposed to not look
like a woman even though she
we tagged it like from the first yeah
yeah yeah oh ty we didn't even really
talk about taskmaster like
what a not a it's just one it's just a
goon like she was just like a
a blank slate who who kind of fought
sort of if you were looking closely like
the other
uh avengers and you had this like
amazing chance to do
um like when like a fight between her
and red guardian
where like she's gonna imitate captain
america and he's gonna like freak out or
something
no they just didn't do anything cool
with it they had like one second of like
black panther and like never really
followed up on it
seemed like wasted potential but i guess
they're all everybody's still alive at
the end
um so we can always expect everyone to
pop up
and yeah ryan pointed out the chat uh
every every moment was shown in the
trailers too that she did yeah it was
like
amazing spider-man 2 where like you saw
the only cool scene
oh well uh taskmaster on disney plus i'm
sure will be sweet
um all right are we we still have
trailer left right yeah we have stars
sister traitor soldier spy florence and
the regime
super borat the manservant's tale
oh a wise spy eh
babe pig in the study boy bruff and call
me dry golfing
the herd stalker the winter sold her
minnie jovovich venice's daughter
the most brutal murder in black widow's
history
you've always been a really good friend
to me
him sees you yeah i didn't understand
the dynamic between her and that guy
i full-grown adult managed to lose a
tic-tac-toe hawkeye
definitely
yeah uh her and and uh ot
i'm not even gonna attempt that name uh
what they um
where is who is he he's he's just like a
fixer yeah yeah he's just like
one of those like guys that can get
anything
yeah i'm just shocked he's the black
best friend except not like the best
friend this time
every marvel movie has a black best
friend he's the closest they could get
uh but he doesn't really get to be the
bestie this time he's the black widow's
best friend yeah i guess so he was there
to be a red herring ryan says for
taskmaster
um or something but like i don't know i
i understand the
impulse to like not overshadow black
widow in her own movie but it's
at the same time like every marvel movie
now has like
cameos all over the place like or at
least oh that's a character from
x it just strikes me as odd that that
wouldn't be
i don't know like ulysses claws still
alive or somebody else
uh you know some kind of person that i
would that i could do the leo point
at this point hey oh hey that's that
guy's son
gingrich or like whatever that one guy
rich or whatever like no he's
he's just a dude who knows how to
somehow get helicopters
i'm just a dude uh yeah well
there you go that was black widow um i
had fun
i had a good enough time watching it
granted i did not pay
for my own wallet or uh uh for disney
premier access thank you fandom
no one did so yeah i don't think
anything was the most pirated
movie of the year is what i think i read
yeah so
you know i i think that probably colors
my perception of it but
um it's been a long time since i did uh
since i watched a marvel movie and it
was like oh yeah that that
it made about as much as like a doctor
strange and i enjoyed it about as much
as like a
like a random b-level marvel movie so
it's it's hard to really get too excited
one way or the other for me about it
it's like uh
these are like the episodes before the
big mid-season finales or or season
premieres
of of marvel the series so i don't know
yeah what's your overall takeaway daniel
yeah no like it was a fun movie is it
gonna be one that i watch over and over
again i will watch that opening over and
over again because like
i genuinely think that that's one of the
best things that they've done
um i think i'll probably skip through
and watch scenes that i like which is
very easy because they all ended up on
twitter
so it's very easy they'll all wind up
being on youtube or something
um but yeah no it's just a just a
mid-tier
like i don't see this being like if i
ever do a re-watch which i'm not going
to do at this point because there's
going to be like 30 of these things in
the next couple of years
um but if i ever did one that would be
like the way that i would re-watch it
but
it's not in my face it really the the
impulse to
or the the compulsion to make the third
act
like an enormous cgi
like fight through the skies like this
if
ever a movie did not not warrant that
but like not
need that like the the the ambush like
taskmaster
like sneaks up on that and blows her up
and they fight and stuff like that
that's probably the best
action scene in the in the movie that or
like the escape at the beginning with
the uh with the plane and stuff like
that
i think there's one more spy stuff more
spy stuff like there's nothing about
her like sky surfing uh like a uh
an exploding um like castlevania castle
in the sky
like the more is not more in this case
like less is a lot more um
including like the duel with the widows
where i saw that they
definitely did practice the time honored
one at a time fighting style
like the whole room is like full of
black widows and then like
you go okay okay now it's your turn yeah
and then like that could have been
i don't know like there was like uh say
what you will about the last jedi but
that red
throne room duel was pretty awesome like
there's ways to do
like one person versus a lot that's very
cool but
she just kind of shot everyone with a
taser and then jumped and then did
another
long fall from a distance so i don't
know missed opportunities to make it
really stand out
but that's that's kind of par for the
course these days isn't it
um and uh and they're still doing real
interesting things over on the tv side
so i i've not lost uh my total interest
in marvel the series the movies the game
the experience the experience uh let's
watch some
outtakes uh sorry if i keep looking i
just got a new monitor so like
now all my now every time i'm looking at
notes or
uh well chad is saying i actually have
it up here there isn't just like a weird
person in my window or anything so
that's now you know that's a little
behind the scenes that's what you get in
commentaries you get
office layouts and uh and deleted scenes
so let's roll those
there's red guardian and over the hill
boar who swears he fought captain
america
even though the timelines don't add up
oh crap that means he beat up old steve
doesn't it
so does this mean he beat up 90's cap
yeah he could probably beat this captain
america
and only captain america can stop him
follow along as nat goes undercover
this thing you do when you lift your
hair when you're fighting
you're a total poser even though she's
already a global celebrity and literally
everyone has seen the avengers
why don't you take it to one of your
super scientist friends tony stark maybe
i hear things something about the
avengers getting divorced
and with you an avenger under my control
you should have brought the avengers
super jet i'm not the one that's on the
cover of a magazine including end game
maybe you'd like a shot at the man
responsible
for your sister's death how does anyone
know that did rescue snitch
i don't think red skull snitched he's
infiltrated the halls of power with a
sister soldier hood of mind-controlled
assassins
yes why did the black widows always die
first
because now that marvel has themselves a
deadpool someone had to become the
deadpool from wolverine origins
i guess gender swamp all you want the
only thing cool about taskmaster is how
they talk smack while they beat your ass
she looks like a capital rider on vocal
rest
starring abp always be
posing room raider from russia with
glove
newcomer east meets vest
polly pockets harboring fugitives
guardians of the family vodka avenger
the mommy returns dr strange
wise on black crime putin on the ritz
analyze this justice for ham
that'll do pig that'll do
oh there you go um yeah it's a
uh the idea that she's undercover
and is like the most famous person in
the world um and i guess all the black
widow
the black widows like you see them on
missions and
it's like five of the most gorgeous
women in the world in like
skin-tight leather bodysuits knife
fighting in the street
it's like i wonder what's going on over
there like there's
zero zero subtlety in uh in the black
widow program but you know what they get
the job done they get the job done i
would assume it was a music video
yeah right yeah they must be filming a
tick tock right there
uh yeah i think what else was for the
delete season oh yeah and i mean same
with red guardian it's like a little
weird that you know if he was russia's
captain america that he'd be like
he would also be a celebrity and like
everywhere and they would say
hey go undercover just uh go
go like uh hide out um
just odd odd choices all right well he
had that wig that wig helped save him
too yeah
something i remember we were talking
about but didn't i guess it didn't make
it in
anywhere was uh uh marvel or pop culture
is really having a moment with uh knife
drops with dropping one knife into
another yeah
they really like that the thing where
for for folks who are wondering what
we're talking about it's that arya stark
thing where you
you drop it like this and then you catch
it like that um
one thing the night king could never
have stopped or
i predicted had two hands no
the right one um yeah i always wonder
what would happen if you wound up like
grabbing the knife end on
accident yeah
that's what they trained you for all
right let's go into well before we
move into comments and questions uh
thank you all for watching
please like please subscribe uh click
that thumb and ring that bell
and you'll never miss another thing and
you'll want to come back for next week
and every week after that because there
we got it we got a good run of trailers
coming up
um so so get excited uh and
uh you have questions so or comments
this one's more of a comment latin bean
dip
says the opening was so good it made the
rest of the movie seem meh
yeah i feel like uh maybe executives
just don't read scripts past page 10 and
they're like oh this is great yeah if
it's like this for the rest of the movie
sold yeah done
you're hired but yes i i don't think the
rest of it lived up to
uh 205 and if you liked it watch the
americans truly one of the better shows
i've seen on tv in the in the spy genre
for sure
um so good uh
okay uh cb writes haley steinfeld's the
reason to be excited for hawkeye yeah
that's true
yeah that's fair it's very fair i'm
curious to see how quickly
they rip the bow from from jeremy
renner's hands and
and be like all right go uh go away um
time to go make us more at more albums
yeah i was going to say you'll always
have the music career
i can all enjoy um
okay warrior fella black widow film is
in between
is it between not one of the best not
one of the worst tops captain marvel and
especially wonder woman 1984.
okay if you're yeah if you're related to
the other female-led superhero movies i
would say this
is um well yeah it's definitely above
those two for me
um where do you put this in your in your
mcu ranking
oh i don't know like i said middle of
the road
i think uh i think we're on the same
page yeah it's pretty mid-tier
yeah um gorilla sonic i don't understand
the hate for hawkeye he is a great hero
yes in the comics i just
i'm not i'm not fond of mr renner's work
um and his uh uh on and off camera so
that's the the the anti-hawkeye bias is
coming from that
um and uh and yeah his band just got it
an mcu battle of the bands because so
many of them have
have these side projects downey's got a
band up scrum chances garage johansen
in like that breathy way you'd expect
she's not like didn't she cover a bunch
of tom wait
songs was that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so um it's a low bar i think uh
i i imagine that um
uh what's his name come on the hulk uh
starts with mark ruffalo i'll bet he's
got a good uh
got a good band or maybe he djs or
something just a hunch
yeah uh okay uh evan j
pretzel ass uh this is for old man
gilbert what smell would you use to stop
people from killing you
i mean i'd rather you know uh do
do something nice rather than something
so stinky that like they couldn't get
close so like you know just like a nice
cedar vanilla-y scent a little cinnamon
that someone would be like oh
are you like baking uh are you making
snickerdoodles
um like a nice yankee candle yeah
it's like you're showing a house yeah
that's the smell
yep um okay uh nick cronus writes uh i
think the reception this movie would
have been so much better if it came out
after civil war or even infinity war
what do you think about that is it the
release order that that kind of painted
this for you
i think so i think it would have been
better if it would have came out after
one of those
for sure and uh yeah no i agree
yeah um fast bowler points out how would
yelena know about
natasha's end poses how would that be
possible
see that's the like everyone seems to
know i guess maybe
like when she's on magazine covers she's
doing the pose
and they're catching her yeah like
they're catching her do it uh
i get i'm still just amazed at that dude
that was inside that
little small station didn't seem to
blink an eye when natasha ramanov walked
in and they started doing her signature
pose just like nothing
yeah uh crazy so uh michael simson
writes what character would people like
to see taskmaster copy taskmaster
jumping around like hulk but with none
of the strength would be hilarious
i agree yeah
[Laughter]
just trying to flip a car but can it be
very uh um
ben stiller and mystery men yeah pants
suddenly become
shorts but it doesn't matter because
you're not like yeah
david i want to know what will happen to
all the freed black widows what are they
going to do
oh yeah this is great in a very like um
end of slavery kind of way it's like
you're free good luck bye
yeah peace out it's not even like they
had a thing where they're like yeah
we're gonna go and we'll teach you how
to like re-enter the world since you've
never actually been in it it's just like
no
you have to think for yourself now peace
it must be fun
if i recall though that did occur on
like a
was that on the slowest crashing uh uh
space station of all time were they in
the air still when she
i think they were in the air still when
they all got freed and then they started
they had to do an accelerated uh
rehab program just like make your own
choices gotta go
it's probably all got snapped anyways so
they could just address it later because
they are
they could just say that they got snaps
yes what a confusing couple of years for
those widows
thank god they all still wear those
suits though yeah
um okay and
um who had the most uh reynard city
update channel ask who had the most
unintentionally hilarious fake accent i
mean
it's ray winston by a mile yeah he was
speaking with
a like thick cockney accent in half of
his lines
and um you just you just love to see it
i think that they have the out
of saying uh oh they're all sokovian but
but they don't take it
yeah you can just say that like these
these things aren't taking place in our
world right
like they're not really just call it
captain shmush america
it's fine um great so
uh that wraps up all the all the good
ones for today
um we will be back next week uh
where let's see um
we have that's too deep of a that's too
deep of a basketball reference for me
so there's your clue there we go there's
a clue
we're doing airbud people come back next
week uh where we finally
tackle that golden retriever and all the
all the little
scamps around him that enable his reign
of terror um
or maybe something related to that but
uh danielle thank you for joining me
uh and thank you audience um i hope you
had fun and we'll do it again soon
that's all for now bye
[Music]
you